you think maybe the uh the government's
failures will result in more people
becoming libertarian
it's like like i was saying these kids
go to school right the system provides
now they're out of school and they're
like where is the system that tell me
what to do and give me food
and then when they realize it failed
maybe they'll be like i better find food
on my own
well i think back to what we basically
started with which is
what did you say you said uh technology
in technology is downstream
culture culture is downstream from so
now what's happening is
like trump definitely usurped the whole
cultures politics is downstream from
culture because i think he kind of just
like
you know maybe there would have been a
trumpian figure elected in a couple of
years if he had to just like literally
hijack that election
um so i think you know that kind of came
to the forefront earlier than it
would have otherwise but no matter what
we're still it's still culture and
politics are both catching up with
technology we're just playing catch up
and the tech the tech monopolies are the
ones who are capitalizing on that
ian makes a really good point that that
culture is downstream from technology
look at what happens with the radio you
have mass communications the printing
press
the printing press allows for the mass
dissemination of propaganda for an
american revolution
you eventually you know you get hundreds
of years of that basically but more and
knowledge is being spread people's
attitudes and their understandings
change
the radio creates a new culture of radio
the style of speaking
the the you know then you get silent
films then films
as more it's communication technology
really that i think is driving culture
in a lot of ways
the rapid spread of behaviors and
information now we get the internet
which has dramatically altered our
culture in a lot of crazy ways
i think a lot of really bad ways and i
think a lot of really good ways not
simple to say one or the other
how do we deal with the bad element the
slamming beating kids over the face with
you know critical race applied
principles
how do we get rid of that bad stuff and
keep the good stuff of kid
you can google it to figure it out for
yourself but you can't really now
because google kind of controls
exactly right you can bring it you can
duck you gotta go to the library
i think you're better off just going to
the library now they're banning books
dude
you can look at how corporations control
the
the narrative with their censorship so
that's a problem that needs to be looked
at you look at other technologies like
fiat currency currency in general as a
technology the
the way the currency is utilized is a
problem that's altering culture in a
massive way oh yeah like
with with the federal reserve it changed
the way people could buy houses what
they could own what they could trade
and it gave centralized authority to a
small group
we have centralized electric grids so
we're we're at the whim
of the government because if they want
to turn the power off we're screwed that
we have centralized water systems
they want to shut the water off we're
screwed so
these technologies are big problems and
i think if we holistically focus on all
of them
we might be able to to seize the culture
but focusing on one of them's just going
to be ramming ahead into a wall no but
it's it's
you got you got to go for the uh the
grassroots you you're not gonna be able
to come out and be like hey everybody
let's totally decentralize all
infrastructure it's gonna be like
well like who's working on what but if
we were like let's figure out a way to
get everybody energy independent
let's figure out a way to give everybody
community independent communications
no one can shut your phone off no one
can ban you no one can silence you how
do we do that
communications is easy for us because
we're all kind of communications people
you know like here we are on an internet
show talking
but what about energy what about fuel or
food resources how do we get people to
become
decentralized which means a lot of
personal responsibility
we need more polymaths among us like ben
franklin
and uh thomas jefferson it's funny
though because when you were describing
like what the media is doing and how
they're like packaging up with these
click farms and stuff like that
i was thinking to like you know 2008 the
way that they packaged up all these
subprime mortgages
and just sold them no you're right
they're like oh yeah they're triple a
and it's like
it's all good as long as you know you
keep you can keep selling the house for
a little bit more
it's okay until all of a sudden you know
those were international scams but
mortgage scandal was an insurance
scandal they didn't want to classified
as insurance because they avoided all
the litigation that would have come
along with it but they were basically
that they're buying insurance what do
you mean uh uh
subprime mortgage there is an insurance
the mortgage-backed securities the
mortgage
those are insurance packages yeah if the
more
if they can't get paid back on the
mortgage so the triple-a rating the
aaa rating is the likelihood of it to
default so so so they were buying their
shirts
talking about media you're exactly right
richie because i was actually uh working
on
the preliminary documentary about this
the ad rights assignment stuff isn't as
prominent as it was as it is today so
it's not as relevant but we could maybe
do a look back
what they were doing was they were
taking bunk views that were worthless
and then packaging them behind aaa rated
news websites
so everybody knows that you know this
website is the gold standard of youth
news
yeah wow 100 million views when it was
really getting 30 million and 70 million
was garbage views from trash
click bait websites where you'd click in
and you'd bounce out in five seconds
but that that was a click and then you
by contract
assign the traffic rights to the aaa
rated company
who then goes to advertisers and says we
get a 100 million views
per month if you want some of this it's
going to cost you 50 grand for an ad
and then the companies are like wow 100
million views we'll buy it
but then the campaigns didn't work you
can't sell ads to nobody
so eventually the bubble burst i mean
that's that
that's fraud i mean facebook as if you
compare it as a
social media ecosystem compared to like
youtube or even instagram
people like an average view time
on facebook is like you know a good one
is like
20 something seconds it's like wow wow
that's so good it was
over 20 seconds yeah like youtube what's
your average view time on your show
uh i think it's uh on this channel like
28
to 30 minutes really exactly and then on
my other channels it's like 14
between 10 and 14 depending on you know
so there are still places where people
can go to like
get qualitative content that they're
actually paying attention to where there
actually is value
and that's you know there are people are
learning that there are ways of
measuring that
so i don't think like it's you know you
know it's a bubble that's gonna burst
necessarily in this
i i think we've got a
our culture is no longer focused you
know
it's it's it's what is it doing it's
like a frankenstein culture
it's got one squid arm and like a peg
leg
it's a half pirate monster just ninja
squid frankenstein frankenstein three
werewolf three classes
in the culture you got the banking class
the merchant class and then
i guess you call it the lower class oh
no
then you've got the communications class
they're all more political classes all
merchants
there's the bankers which are running
everything then there's the merchants
which are sucking off
and basically funding and capitalizing
they're like business owners and things
like that
and then there's all the workers that's
that's i completely disagree
one of the most annoying things about
occupy wall street was when this guy
stood up and screamed during a general
assembly fracking
is the problem it's the center of
everything
and then i busted out laughing like this
guy is so myopic
in his view that he thinks fracking is
the problem
i mean we can start with the federal
reserve that i can give you but to claim
that small business owners and amazon
are in the same merchant class is just
completely incorrect
to claim that both merchants mark
zuckerberg
who is in the same class as a
mom-and-pop candy shop is is not
not it is not sound it doesn't make
sense you've got
tech elites who manipulate what people
can and can't do the communications
companies who can take who can shut off
your cell phone
who can track your cell phone who can
give your information to the government
you've got the intelligence agencies
the permanent government then you've got
the political class the liars who get
voted
there are so many different groups of
people all colluding to extract value
from the system that's why i call it a
mass frankenstein monster
of various cultures all just shambling
around falling it's gonna fall over
what was once you know it's this it's
the ship of theseus
that's probably the way best way to
describe i'm familiar with these yes
so so uh the the uh right ship of
theseus i'm talking about right that i'm
thinking of
theseus was the guy with the golden fl
the golden fleece you know
the the ship is that you know how many
if you take take one piece off and
replace it
how long until i thought he he slayed
the minotaur right i don't know anything
about his book is it is it theseus
i don't know i don't remember i'm sorry
you lost me i think it is familiar with
them
let's see what the commenters are saying
let's find out our audiences
yeah okay yeah i'm right yeah so the
ship of theseus is that let's save a
boat
and then you remove one piece of wood
and then and replace it with a brand new
piece of wood
is it still the ship of theseus that's
how he got home yeah okay
now you replace it with another piece of
wood do that until all
of the original pieces have been removed
and replaced is it still the original
ship of theseus
then take the remaining pieces and
rebuild the ship of theseus now you have
two which one's the real one
it's an interesting thought boats don't
have souls
well so here's the issue countries do
yeah and so
if from the start of the american uh
country experiment they want to call it
we had the ship of america
and one by one we've replaced parts and
put in different parts
the problem is they're not the same
piece if you had like a 12 by 4 piece of
wood plank and removed it with like a
3x9 it's not going to work properly
and now we're at the point where we have
not rebuilt the ship of theseus
we've created this weird amalgam of
competing interests that's shambling
along and starting to sink
i don't know i'm maybe more optimistic
because i i think back
like just a generation or two ago i mean
we literally had a global war we had a
cold war where everybody thought they
were going to get
nuked and talk about the red scare talk
about being scared about communism
taking over america
i mean that was literally like bro the
threat of
annihilation was like you wanted to get
on your desk and just prepare to get
vaporized you're right like at every
turn and one of those superpowers
collapsed and does that mean the united
states could not be facing the same
thing
we're facing collapse and then china
wins is what you're saying maybe it's a
new cold war and who says we're gonna
win it but i think
you know i like to think that america's
and the constitution is more resilient
it's like the ship that you're talking
about the constitution ensures that we
can
you know revise and and open free and
open society ensures that we can
correct ourselves and the tide can ebb
and flow between you know whatever you
want to call it left and right
libertarian
authoritarian i love the constitution
but where was the constitution when jake
gardner
was being threatened and his family was
being attacked and then he got choked
i never yeah i never said it was perfect
and like that situation that's so
devastating
that's not the fault of the constitution
that's why i said earlier you can have
the law
and then you have the culture and if the
culture doesn't support the law the law
doesn't make any sense or doesn't matter
so when black lives matter can literally
go around destroying buildings causing
two billion dollars in damage and face
no repercussions and gains support from
all the major massive multinational
corporations
the law doesn't matter does it but dude
we had we had the bill of rights when
there were still slaves like there was a
right like the law didn't matter but it
was the culture it changed and the
culture
changed and and generally the culture
bent in the direction of actual genuine
progress and
in the in the in the moment where you're
in between the waves you know it's
really hard to see over the next one but
you know if you take a much broader view
of american history you realize like
wow like every generation thought that
they were in this dire crisis and they
thought that america was doomed and yet
it's so resilient and it's like i think
it's partially a byproduct of like
you know like you said the soul the
country does have a soul and it is this
i don't i think the american dream is
still alive and so far as people still
come here
because so for a reason and people
aren't flooding into china our
understanding of free speech is new
right 100 years ago free speech didn't
exist the way we think it does
so the bill of rights almost didn't
matter you had a very moralistic
authoritarian style of culture
you can't say these things you can't
dress this way now we have a very very
libertarian
but the problem is a new moral
authoritarianism is on the rise
of course the united states will exist
probably in name but who knows what
it'll actually be
right like you mentioned when the bill
of rights was created there were slaves
right because the bill of rights didn't
matter so much as the culture mattered
what the people were willing to tolerate
and willing to do so we can
talk about making the country better and
moving towards freedom which is what i
think we've typically done
the problem is now the dominating
faction is
anti-freedom and pro-collectivist which
means we're going backwards
in fact these people outright want to
rewind the clock on civil rights
i'll give you the easiest example to
understand so people can so people can
truly understand what's happening okay
ibrahim ex candy the ant the guy who the
anti-racism guy
what's his real name though i don't know
i thought it was even good
it's henry rodgers yeah i think oh it is
shout out to henry rodriguez is it henry
rogers it's true yeah he's also a guy
i only know that because a guy at the
daily caller so alexandria
cortez he's like the whitest guy ever so
it's funny alexandria ocasio-cortez says
why don't peop these republicans you
know want schools to teach the kids to
be anti-racist
anti-racist i love that word anti-race
so smart
because people who have no idea what's
going on say oh i hate racism
i want to be anti-racist but what does
kennedy say
he says anti-racism the only solution
for past discrimination
is present discrimination and the only
solution for present discrimination
is future discrimination right that's an
er that's a quote from candy yep
he genuinely believes we should have
racial discrimination
now i think discriminating on the basis
of race is evil
don't you i think most people agree with
that in america okay
so let's replace discrimination with
evil so candy's statement is
the only solution to past evil is
present evil and the only solution to
present evil is future evil
why would i want someone who is evil to
have any power at all well
discrimination is not evil
it can be used in an evil way but you
have to discriminate if you have a hot
rock and a cold rock you know that you
don't want to pick up the hot rock you
have to discriminate between the rocks
as to which one is safe to touch
so i'm i'm obviously not being 100
absolute i am
making a my point using hyperbole and
exaggerating
clearly there are instances where
general discrimination doesn't mean
discriminate against human beings
you know but even then like one guy's
super tall and one guy is super short
and you need someone to pick the
apples up there you got it you got to
hire the tall guy which is it right
right right so
i think the issue with like that frame
of thinking is
most people probably understand my point
but arguing the semantics of it doesn't
actually i don't think
i don't think there's a lot of
situations where discriminating on race
has any value
can you think of one medical uh sickle
cell oh yeah yeah so there are times
when you need to discriminate based on
race for people's safety
what i'm saying is that ibram kendy's
view is that we should form policies
that affect people's lives and access to
civil rights
based on their race when my view is
mostly a negative rights aspect of
we should not impose restrictions based
on their race so they can always enjoy
full civil rights
now of course the left argues but
they're not being allowed full civil
rights because of racism and i'm like
private actors do private things and
they're bad people
the system has already been healing from
this for 50
was it 56 57 years they they complain
about you know these these
uh uh redlining and blockbusting and i'm
like yes we have been
solving for that it's not perfect we've
passed the laws
now we're trying to solve that problem
but you are now
bringing us back you're saying you are
going
to bring back racial discrimination i'm
like you're making things worse
but don't you think okay but you know
don't you think that the
the same tide that ebden flowed in order
to allow for the civil rights
movement and i'm not drawing the same
parallel i'm just speaking in terms of
cultural shifts you know the mainstream
the people who are quote-unquote
revolutionaries trying to change the
system
actually able to create you know
progress
quote unquote and obviously that's a
charged term but don't you think that
most people don't think in america don't
think like ibram x candy and
it's just that everybody's scared to
speak up right now right because
they have a fear of you know that their
digital self
being maligned to the point where their
real self is you know
from society they are more scared of
being called a racist
than of their children being
indoctrinated into a moralistic
authoritarian
i think that's i think that's generally
right but
it's still america and it's not did the
people in this so
russian but the soviet union sucked it
was a [ __ ] system
and america is the best system that's
ever made flawed as it may be
and sorry that i i just no no no no no
hold on
that point's completely irrelevant the
soviet union was garbage
and the people hated it and it stood for
100 years
yes the united states system is an
amazing system
but people still are doing nothing to
stop the central planners and the
communists from seizing power
so hey american marxism mark levin's
book sold 500 000 copies in like a week
yeah there's
and we see a lot of amazon number ones
800 school boards they're up in arms
about it this show
focuses on it there's 98 000 schools bro
yeah but only you'll need five thousand
of them then you only need five percent
of them
yes i i think i i kind of agree in that
in so far as like
it only takes a few people to stand up
to a corrupt system like soulja
nietzsche
who wrote the gulag archipelago and was
able to bring
the whole system down based upon one man
who stood up and
literally how the hell he memorized the
whole thing no i'm not
no i'm getting an incredible it only
takes one of those incredible people now
i'm gonna make sense
now i'm gonna imagine you're antifa
saying the exact
same verbatim quote right now and that
means
it's a coin toss i don't think it's a
coin toss because i i don't think
ultimately it doesn't matter what the
ideology is behind it it's like
common sense is common sense and they're
saying the same
thing yeah and if people are scared to
speak up and talk about what they
believe and they're willing to cower
then you've got one violent faction
who's been given carte blanche because
the establishment rarely if ever says
anything bad about them
and another faction that is being
persecuted and prosecuted to a growing
and more extreme degree
so you're right you know what's what's
the saying from
what's that woman you know let never be
said that a small group of determined
people have you know couldn't change
history indeed it's like they never have
uh sure but that's also true of your
political opponents
you know history is written by the
victors and you look at what happens in
you know threat history with civil wars
and and conquest and the people who are
able to win and write the books down and
spread those ideas are the ones who win
right now you have a growing faction of
extremist
critical race theorists and their
critical race applied principles
and you have a much smaller group of
people who are willing to actually stand
up
and challenge it there are a lot of
people willing to challenge it there are
more people by the day
but there's also more antifa people it
was it was eight percent progressive
according to the hidden tribes report
three years ago the the last poll i
checked it was like 10
10 or 11 percent they've grown they've
grown power for a few reasons
they're getting more young people like i
mentioned those fourth graders
nine more years and you will have fully
fledged adult marxists
who believe all that stuff and it's
their whole whole life that's if we
don't do anything about it yeah
i mean i would look to like europe or
canada and like
you know jordan peterson being a good
example of like we were talking about
one person standing up i mean he was the
only guy in the entire education system
uh in canada who was like whoa oh you're
compelling our speech and you want to
like make it criminal for me not to you
know
say if i make him whatever if you say
the wrong pronoun i think it was
basically
you you could be criminal and if you
don't pay your fine you can't go to jail
and so he stood up against it and look
at what happened you know
there was this like global support that
came behind him
solely because he was that one guy
willing to stand up and and that's in
like much more
you know i think less free societies
than we live in so
i think the tide's shifting dude and i
feel good about this sure sure what i'm
saying is
in nine years we will have that that
fourth grader a fully fledged marxist
obviously it's if we do nothing the
point is we're here trying to do
something people need to pay attention
they need to understand what what it
means to get involved they need to
understand what it means to speak up at
their workplace
challenge these systems refuse to
support them if
you know a company wants to get work
they can go broke one guy messaged me
and he's like i listen to the show
every night with my two daughters one's
10 and one's 13 and the 10 year old
asked them something they were all
listening to in the car and the 10 year
old asked something then the 13 year old
was like
it doesn't matter the government's going
to fall apart anyway
we're seeding these thoughts into kids
so we got to be careful optimism
conscious about what we say what we want
to happen
and how we frame things i don't think
personally that there are more
i don't think this stupid racist
movement is growing
i think that it showed its head it's
obviously deranged
most people see that you know what ian
you're right and my biggest fear is that
you know if if we don't do something
then then the libertarians are going to
take over and
dave smith will become president oh man
oh man worst case scenario we're seeding
these ideas
oh no we don't do anything the mises
caucus and libertarian party are gonna
are gonna take over i'm kidding that'd
be great
you're right the stakes are high though
and i i agree that it's not it's nothing
that's
it's not a trivial thing and it's not
something that people just should just
say oh you know it's just happening
in you know blue check twitter zone
because
um i think you know all of us are kind
of the byproduct of i don't know how old
are you i'm like 42.
you're 42. yeah that's great right what
[Music]
because i think you know being born in
89 we're about the same age
like i was definitely part of the
generation of everybody gets a trophy
that's for sure yeah me too and like i
don't know no i wasn't you were like a
rub you're
rub some dirty get a job when you're 12.
yeah yeah we're not paying you allowance
anymore
go out there you know it was one of my
walk a dog one of the worst feelings i
ever had i remember i was in third grade
and they were doing this like thing at
my school where there was like they had
but it was like an after-school program
thing
like parents were there and they were
asking trivia questions and i was just a
little smart kid right
so i would raise my hand but the teacher
would never call on me and so then i
started crying
because i didn't get a chance to
actually answer the question and win the
prize
so i was just a given one and i was like
that was like the most brutal thing ever
it felt
miserable i was like i don't want it i
must have i wanted to answer the
question
i missed it by like by like six years or
something i think the internet
i don't know what what brought that on
that everybody gets a trophy
it's uh well i think it's actually what
tim was talking about earlier which is
that
the people who uh basically occupied the
positions of you know being our teachers
were the children of that that kind of
counterculture movement of the late 60s
you know they're basically hippies
they're the ones who went into
humanities to teach your kids english
and
whatever tommy's you know teach your
kids how to how to critically think
but we still you know we still read like
uh
tom sawyer and stuff like we still had
to contend with those difficult topics
and
and that's right thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show
come back to this channel
youtube.comcast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time